honoring the member memory of a victim
of one october
this weekend a scholarship fundraiser is
being held in the name of quentin
robbins
every year his family puts on a golf
tournament to help local athletes
succeed
our hector mejia live near lake las
vegas with their efforts hey hector
hey there good morning and the annual
fundraiser is back this weekend on
saturday it did not happen last year
because of the pandemic
check out this beautiful view this is
where it's taking place this is
reflection bay golf club
overlooking beautiful lake las vegas and
i should mention
thanks to the immense support from the
entire community across the valley
they expect a full house this weekend
you can still support their efforts by
donating
any day of the year the quentin robbins
play it forward foundation was
established in honor of 20 year old
quinton robbins
he was among the youngest victims killed
in the one october shooting
he loved sports playing basketball and
golf all four years that he was at basic
high school
the money raised this weekend will fund
scholarships for students at his former
schools
brown junior high and basic high
we want to focus on the positive and
that's what we can take away from this
tragedy
is to try to move forward and to help
others through that foundation
and you know appreciate the individuals
that were like him
and help them through their lives so
they can in turn do the same
that was joe robbins the father of
quentin robbins
uh student athletes are awarded with one
thousand dollars for
college or vocational programs the funds
also pay for sports programs in
henderson
and las vegas and here's one more thing
the foundation is run as a non-profit
all made up of volunteers including
family and close friends
we also talked about the selection
process you know some students
don't even know they were nominated when
they received the award
you'll hear more about that still ahead
in the next half hour reporting live
this morning right next to a beautiful
sunrise hector mejia
8 news now back to you